STACY DEVINO: going to tell
you a little bit about myself.
I'm Senior Android
Innovator at Home Depot.
I work on a lot of
different stuff.
I'm the Techmaker
Lead for Dallas,
SixSigma BlackBelt,
Intel Innovator,
a bunch of other stuff that
you don't really care about,
because you're here to learn.
You don't care who I am.
Come on.
But there's some
contact information
and things like that
in case you want
to ask me further questions or
throw me extra tips and tricks.
I'm always up for hearing what
kind of creative solutions
worked for you.
So here are some of
the biggest issues
that we face with mobile
networks on applications.
Large, unfiltered
images-- your API
is servicing you stuff
that's meant for desktops.
It's not meant for tiny screens.
But you have tiny
networks, so you
need a way to make
those things tiny.
So we also have issues
with on track data usage.
Do we really need to
be constantly hitting
our usability API when
the user is not actually
using the application?
Do we need to constantly be
tracking what they're doing
while it's not even active?
Probably not.
You can have non-optimized
network handling.
So are you putting your batches
of bundled data together,
or are you just
constantly hitting it
whenever you want to?
And just bad API designs,
not using the Android tools.
And one that's pretty awful
that I see fairly often,
doubled API calls.
Why do you need to try it twice?
And it's one of
those things that
can be hard to figure out if
it's happening or if it's not.
So I'm going to show you how.
So how do you track
your application data?
You can use the
Android tools, which
Google has been really
great about giving you
instructions on how to do that.
But there's more
stuff out there.
If you're watching for
your APIs and responses,
I'd strongly
suggest that you use
something called Charles Proxy.
It's not free, but it's
worth it, especially
if you need to check are you
sending the correct API data
and are you getting
the right return data.
Is your stuff formatted
like it's supposed to be,
or is it kind of jumbled?
Now, I'm not going to cover
that in this discussion.
I'm just giving it a props
so that you guys can actually
go and look.
There's a ton of
great information
already out there
for Charles Proxy.
So we're going to be
talking a little bit more
about detailed tracking
of network data.
Now, we've all probably
heard about Wireshark,
but you probably haven't
heard of something
called the Application Resource
Optimizer, which is commonly
known as ARO by AT&T. And it's
the easiest thing for you guys
to use who are not used to
tracking stuff down by looking
at, oh, this packet had XYZ.
Let's go into that a little bit.
So we're just going to say
this is how you capture PCAP,
which is the file
that's actually
used to insert into the tool.
And this is where say having a
rooted phone for development,
at least one of them around,
is always super helpful,
because it's a lot more
of a pain in the butt
to get the same information
from a non-rooted device.
But you can see,
it's pretty easy.
What you do is
you basically stop
all your other
applications from running
that are not part
of the core services
and just run your application.
And while you do that, you make
sure that you have this file
being generated by TCP dump.
And then from there, you
just copy it off the device
after you've done
what you need to do.
And we also-- you've got to
specify which kind of interface
you're using.
So are you using Wi-Fi or are
you using cellular networks?
So you'll actually see
that if you do an IPADDR.
That way, you can see what
network interface is actually
active and what are
you actually using.
So download and install-- think
you guys can figure this out,
but this is more just
for reference material.
Again, these slides
will be available
after this discussion.
So what do you get
once you put your file
into this magical tool?
Well, the first page gives
you this lovely summary
of exactly what is
good and what is bad.
And what we can
see here is, hey,
I've got green checkmarks
across the board.
Everything looks pretty good.
There's no major flaws.
There's no major
issues popping up.
This is kind of a
dream situation.
Now, granted, we could
do a little bit better
on that trace score, because
663 out of 1,000 isn't amazing.
But it's giving us-- hey,
we have no major flaws,
no major issues.
And if you are just
making sure, quick glance,
you maybe added a
new feature, you
can pop it into here, go,
oh, everything looks cool.
All right.
That's my smoke test.
So let's just say there's
a blue competitor that
wanted to track
our stuff against
to make sure that we were ahead
of them in the retail industry.
I think it's kind of
implied who that might be.
But just as you can
track your own data,
you can track your
competitor's, too,
and you can track exactly
how good they're performing
and where you're actually
going to be able to even learn
from their mistakes and be
able to figure out what they're
doing right if they're beating
you out in certain areas.
So what's something that we
see going wrong right here?
Now, I understand the
actual text is pretty small,
but we can see that, oh,
there's not good cache control.
That means there's not cache
headers on some of those assets
that are being pulled in.
We also see that, hey,
maybe these images
are pretty big that really
shouldn't be happening.
Now, for both as a comparison, I
performed the exact same search
on their app as it
was performed on mine,
and then also tapped on
an item after the search,
fully loaded the page, and
made sure that before doing so,
we loaded about
100 search results.
So this is the exact same data
in terms of user interaction
on both sides.
So we also see
that-- oh my gosh,
they're not minifying
any of their JSON, CSS,
stuff like that?
Not just any, but there might
be an issue with one or two
things.
So this is what it looks like if
you scroll down on that summary
and you have an issue.
It'll be a nice, big, red box
that tells you what is wrong
and maybe even how to fix it.
So here we're
saying, oh, we just
tested-- it doesn't
look like you have
the presence of cache headers.
Now, that could be an issue
down the road, because what
if somebody who needs to
go back to that resource
or you have another thing
that uses that same resource?
That has to be redownloaded, and
that can be a pretty big thing.
So why would you do
that to your user
when you're within
the same session?
I can understand getting rid of
it after the session is over,
but you're still there,
so why not hold onto it?
So here's the other
issues that we saw.
And this is where it gives
you that information,
and you can see I've blurred
out any of the people that
might be involved.
So you can see that the
images are a little too big.
These were the images
that it pulled up.
These actually looked to
be desktop quality when
I actually went to
those links and looked
at them, which can be
really nice if you have
a very high quality device.
But I was testing on a
couple of different devices,
and some of them were
not high quality devices,
so it ended up taking up a
lot more space with actually
no positive outcome from it.
And again, the minify
of all of that, you
could have saved 7% just by
getting rid of empty spaces.
7% of that whole string
could have been saved.
So another cool thing
you can do with this tool
is you can actually
dictate your own profile.
So if you wanted to track
something that was maybe
a really small
network-- you have
a certain set of parameters
that you're exactly
trying to meet in a
certain set of conditions--
you can actually tell it exactly
what you want to have happen.
Is your target, OK, I only want
to use 95 millijoules of energy
to perform this transaction.
Am I good or am I not?
So this can actually give some
of that information inferred
based off of knowing how much
power is used by the radio,
and you can actually set that so
it makes it really easy for you
to test this in the future.
So here's an overview of
what our data looked like.
So it's showing
a lot of unknown.
Now, normally it
would show a lot
of images JPEG or images PNG.
But we're doing some things
to obfuscate some of that
and do some actual data
batching to make that
a little more
efficient, so it's not
going to be immediately
recognizable that, hey, that's
a JPEG file.
But you can see doing a
lot of search results,
we got a lot of JSON requests.
And we can see, hey,
it moved pretty fast.
We weren't using a
crazy amount of data,
and it generally
looked pretty good.
Now, if you're familiar
with Network Monitor,
the diagnostics are going
to look very, very similar.
So we're looking at this from
a forensic point of view,
and you can see exactly
what happened when I was
going through various points.
So when I first load
it, that's the gray.
Then we have the first
burst of the big red, which
is me performing the search.
Then there's some little dots
for loading extra search result
data when going down
and scrolling more
and fetching and
getting that stuff in.
And then you can
actually see, oh,
when do I actually tap
on-- tap on an item,
and then I tap on an
image of the item.
So I got to the image
page, and then I
tapped on the big images.
So you can see
exactly what that was
and what was the amount of
time that I was actually
using what they call RRC.
Basically, it's how much
radio time were you using.
Was it a lot?
Was it the whole thing
of the bandwidth at once?
And it really wasn't.
You can see it was kind of
yellow and kind of green.
And when you're dealing with
an immediate user interaction
where you are the
forefront application,
that's actually pretty awesome,
because quite a few of them
will run very, very red to
do the same kind of thing.
And you can also
see at the bottom
that you actually
get what ports, what
were your endpoints, what
traffic was going where,
and how much of it.
So we have a Statistics
page as well.
So we actually get to see how
big were the packets that I was
sending, how long did it
go, how fast was I running,
and what's my score.
What did I do really well at,
and what can I improve at?
So in this case, I really
could improve a lot
on my tightly
grouped connections.
So holding one connection
and then not maybe
having a whole bunch of
different server requests
of a bunch of
different endpoints
would probably increase
some of my efficiency.
I know it's hard with external
libraries and things like that
to make that work, but it
does give you some niceties
down the road.
Now, also signaling overhead.
That means I had
a lot of headers.
I had a lot of other
stuff and things
like JSON, certain API requests
that I could improve on.
So now we get down to
something that I am super
passionate about.
Compression is your friend.
It is always your friend.
It is never not your friend
unless you're doing encryption,
too, but that's a
whole different thing.
Filter your images, people.
Filter them.
I am so sick of seeing
40-megabyte PNG big photo
downloads that have no reason
to exist on a mobile phone
even if you're doing mobile
editing of the actual pictures.
There's no reason for it.
So why not use
something that's going
to be giving you the exact same
experience for the customer,
but it's so much more efficient?
In real life, you can actually
take a 42-megabyte PNG image
and bring it down to
about 185 kilobytes.
And that's at something
that is quad HD.
That's a quad HD image.
So that's the nicest devices
you can pretty much buy now,
not counting the 4K ones,
because that's ridiculous.
Nobody can see it.
It's using a lot of battery.
It doesn't make any sense.
Im going, well, apparently,
seven-inch phones
are a thing now.
But in this case,
you can actually
get what is considered
85% quality.
That means you have a
15% compression applied
that basically gives you almost
all of the exact same quality
as what you had
for the PNG file.
Now, there are some
downsides to that.
So JPEG doesn't
support transparency.
So when we're
looking at something
that does support transparency,
what are we also looking at?
Now you're down to P&G or WebP.
WebP is awesome.
I just wish WebP was
supported on more stuff.
Because most of us who
live in the real world
have a situation where
those mobile assets have
to work not only for
you, Android team,
but maybe also for
your mobile web team
and for your iPhone
team, and you
have to be able to design
effectively, especially
if you have limited
resources, to make sure
that that's an actual thing.
I know we all are
going, oh, praise WebP.
And I understand it's great, but
the real world sucks sometimes,
and this is one of
those scenarios.
So it combines the best features
of JPEG and PNG into WebP.
So you get the compression and
you also get the transparency.
But if you have stuff
that needs to go
to somebody else, good luck.
But let's also look at this.
So there's different
types of color space
that you have to work with.
So when we look at
regular images that
are stored into
memory on Android,
they're going to be ARGB 8888.
That's just the
way that they load.
It always takes up the
same amount of space.
You save nothing
on memory loading
by using these smaller
compressed images.
They will always take up pretty
much the same exact amount
of memory.
Doesn't matter which
of these you pick.
This is just helping
you on transport.
You need to use
the bitmap options
when you do loading of
an image to make sure
that you're using only a
certain amount of memory.
But I'm sure most
of you guys know
that, because the out
of memory error sucks,
and it really sucks to see
it on your log reports.
And images are one of
the biggest things that
will cause those
things to happen,
especially full-page images.
And somebody who's
got a $50 phone,
they don't really
think about the fact
that, well, maybe it
might have some issues,
because it was a $50 phone.
So let's think about this.
If you need transparency,
you basically
need to look at ARGB,
either 4444 or 8888.
8888 is full everything.
But what would ARGB
4444 be good at?
It's really awesome at
simplified iconography.
Something like a lot
of the material design
pictures, photographs,
things like that do amazing
and look exactly the same
if you look at the ARGB
8888 versus the 4444.
And you've just saved a
ton of bits by doing so.
You've essentially cut
your package in half.
It's awesome.
But OK-- well, I don't
need transparency,
but I would really
appreciate having
all that nice little
compression thing going on
without losing anything.
So we're not reducing
the color space.
We just take away transparency,
and that gives you the RGB 565.
So you get full color.
You get all the nice
gradients that you
don't get in ARGB 4444, but it
gives you all the same things
that you would expect
in a JPEG image--
just you haven't even gone
to the lossy compression
at this point.
So if I asked you what to
use on a certain thing,
you now have a table that you
can take to your UI/UX guys
and say, hey, look at this.
Which one is it?
So here's the too long, didn't
read for image filtering.
Basically, JPEG whenever
possible or WebP
if you're so lucky that
you get your own APIs.
If you have
iconography, 4444 it.
Compress all your images.
I need to say this once, twice,
three times-- compress them.
Everybody as a group--
compress your images.
Oh, that was really lame.
Come on.
Everybody, I want you to
believe this mantra-- compress
your images.
All right.
And don't be afraid
to use lossy formats.
I know it can be a
little bit daunting.
And if you have a UI
guy who's just going,
oh, this pixel looks ever so
slightly a little messed up
or whatever--
well, he's probably
the only guy who's holding
a phone right up to his eye.
So it's OK.
You can get virtually
the same effect
by just cutting out
some of the extra
that you just don't need
for rendering purposes.
If you're doing a photo
editing app, different problem.
This is not the session for you.
Google Photos people do
really good work on that.
I don't know how they
get that to load so nice,
but I'm sure they have a
lot of people doing it.
And compression on
the network is not
compression in your heap.
So it's going to load the
same size no matter what.
And you know what else?
You should probably
design your APIs
to handle multiple screen sizes.
So now we need to go to how
do I make that so I can track
for all those different
screen sizes and networks
at the same time.
So you need to adjust it based
off of your network type.
This is code.
Use it.
It's a broadcast receiver.
It tells you when stuff
changes different networks,
and it gives you a little speed
value-- either 0, 1, 2, or 3.
3 is fast.
1 is not very fast.
0 is nothing.
And it gives you the ability
to make just a simple call--
hey, what's my network
currently look like?
So if you're looking at this--
it sounds really cool, right?
But how do you actually
take this and make
it look like real things?
So if you look at that
giant image on the left,
those are all of the popular
screen sizes in Android
and their resolutions.
We're not even talking
about stuff that's old.
This is stuff within
the last two years.
So that's a lot of
different resolutions
and a lot of different
scales that you have
to account for as a developer.
Now, when you think about full
page images, ads, proportions,
making the user experience feel
the same between all of them,
it's kind of a big deal.
So how do I take that and
condense it down to something
that I can handle
giving to a UI guy
and not having to explain a lot?
Really, what you can do is only
worry about three main sizes.
And this even includes your
iPhone and Android and mobile
web rendering pieces.
It can all be convergent.
You really only need to have
them make it in three sizes.
Those three sizes
are 1536 by 1904,
which is essentially your 4 by
3, which also works on iPad.
Woo hoo!
Well, especially some of
the older ones, it's nice.
And then 1440 by
2268, and that's
accounting for the nav bar.
So what we have here is
basically 4K with nav bar
and 4K with hardware buttons.
And those are just
different scales.
Now, what's cool is that
basically most of your iPhone
stuff will fit into the 16 by
9 for quad K, quad HD scaling,
and you don't have to
worry about that as much.
So basically, your
images for Samsungs,
you can basically make them
work on your iPhones, too.
So here is wonderful
predetermined high, medium,
and low settings for
these different ratios
and what devices
they might be on.
So you can actually
take these values
and directly integrate
them into your own system.
Now, this was based off of what
we considered in scope as far
as devices go.
So this is the stuff
that we wanted to target.
We want to target
really high end,
and we target
really low end, too.
Because we know that not every
guy who works in construction
wants to have a $500 phone
that's going to break.
You drop it once, it shatters.
So having something that's a
little more durable but maybe
not as high
performance-- we still
need to take care
of that customer.
So these values, super useful.
Those are the three main scales.
And that way, you can
just have it re-size.
You can actually script this all
in something like ImageMagick
so that you get all of that
stuff already coming out,
and your UI/UX guy never
even knew that he did it.
So here's another technique
that we need to talk about.
It's called data batching.
We need to put our
data together when
we're using mobile
networks or when
our users are moving around.
So we can bundle it
ourselves-- so you
wait to offload bigger data
sets till the user is on Wi-Fi
or some sort of bigger network,
especially if you're not
the main app at the time.
JSON is not very efficient.
XML is terrible.
They've basically made these
human readable formats, which
means that they have a
whole bunch of extra stuff
that the user doesn't care
about and that honestly,
in a lot of cases, you
probably don't need.
But I know it's hard
to get away from this,
because a lot of APIs use JSON.
It's really easy use.
Yeah.
It's really easy to use.
But even CSV is more efficient.
And there's already
tools within Android
that allow you to take advantage
of some of these batch data
files and binaries.
Now, you can also
do bundled together.
And the best thing to do is
to do both at the same time.
So you can use the
GCM Network Manager
and just look at their API for
that in Android, and that way,
it will automatically
bundle your pre-bundled data
in with other things so that
it uses up less radio time
and it better tracks against
faster networks, especially
when the user isn't actively
using your application.
So too long, didn't
read API structure--
use lower quality images
and lower quality networks.
Time to the user matters.
You only have a few hundred
milliseconds before they
notice your app is slow.
And they don't think about the
fact-- when they look at it,
they think your app is slow.
They don't think, hey,
oh, my network sucks
or my phone is slow.
That's not what the first
thing in their mind is.
So even if you need
to get a lower quality
image because you're on
a lower quality network
and then be able to move it to
a higher quality network when
they get there and reload
that image, that's fine.
It's actually going to end up
creating a better experience
for them in the long run.
Now, it's also kind of nice if
you allow your users to dictate
if they want this behavior.
So somebody who's an interior
designer with something
like the Home Depot
app would maybe really
care about getting really high
quality images all the time.
Maybe they don't want
this network optimization.
Giving them the ability
to do that and say,
well, maybe I have a really,
really small data plan-- maybe
I always want low
quality images.
So there's different ways
you can help get more users
to continually use your app.
So you need to batch your
data, especially when
your application is not
the main application up
and use the GCM Network Manager.
It's really easy.
And even for your regular data,
having it batched like that,
it works pretty darn fast.
So there's very few issues that
I've encountered with that.
So thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
So just a special thanks
to Google Developers and/or
Performance Patterns and Big
Android BBQ team and Home Depot
that I work for.
And they let me be here,
so that was pretty great.
I'm not at work today.
It's awesome.
But yeah, so I have
a question for you,
and it involves prizes.
So what's the name of the tool
that I was talking about that
makes it really easy for people
who don't understand networks
to understand networks?
All right.
You were the first guy.
What?
ARO?
Can you actually name the full--
what was the full name of it?
Not just ARO.
What was the full name?
OK.
You you'll get one.
You guys both get one.
It's OK.
Come on up.
You could have.
And then I'm going to
ask more questions.
Yes, it is.
All right.
So if you were paying
attention fairly recently,
how many aspect
ratios do you actually
need to care about
for your images?
Three.
Well, don't just say it.
OK.
Three.
OK there you go.
OK.
So if I'm looking at this
correctly-- what's my TLDR?
OK.
What image format
should you be using
for a majority of
your images that
don't require transparency?
So you gentlemen
were-- yes, you were
the first to raise your hand.
Or-- well, you're
correct either way.
Or JPEG or WebP, so I
would accept all three.
But this one's got
your name on it, buddy.
And everybody gets a
Home Depot football,
foam football over here.
So everybody wins.
This is America, apparently.
We're all winners.
All right, sir.
So what's the name of a
certain API within Android
that makes it really easy for
you to bundle all your data?
Guy in the far back.
You win, sir.
The final one is for you.
So does anybody
have any questions?
Oh, wow.
OK.
Lots of questions.
You, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STACY DEVINO: You're going
to have to repeat that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STACY DEVINO: So I have
looked at that a little bit.
It really-- so yes, I have.
It's just that having
that implemented--
I'm unaware of anybody
who's actually moving
towards that at this point.
So it would be nice, but
it's just not happened
at this stage, I don't think.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STACY DEVINO: Yes.
It's defined by
that, because it's
hard to pull data
from-- as to what
your exact speed on that
network is at that point.
There are some tools that
allow you to do that.
And I've also done
direct tracking.
So for those numbers,
those are based off
of me basically using NU TTCP
to test against my own servers
to see, OK, what does this look
like, what does that look like
where possible.
But it's very-- unless you have
something that's constantly
pinging, you're never
going to know exactly what
time responses and
how quickly something
is moving without actually--
this you get for free.
This is information that's
broadcast by the system
and that you can just plop
it in and you can immediately
make the best inference that
you can as far as the network
quality goes.
And also, be pretty smart when
it comes to how you're actually
putting stuff together.
So my average speed when we
were using the application
was only like 43
kilobytes per second.
That's pretty small.
So that means that that
could actually-- I've
made it so that I'm not
constantly hitting big numbers
and I'm using as little
network as I can,
even though I was on a
super high quality network.
By condensing things, I'm
able to make that happen.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STACY DEVINO: So
you can do both.
This is basically just-- if
you have something that's
critical like that, it's
probably best to do both,
but it's extra
computational overhead.
And something like
this allows you
to-- especially when you're not
the primary network-- sorry,
not the primary
application up-- maybe
you're just making sure that
that user session stays active,
or you're passing
back some metrics
that you collected
while they were actually
using the application,
but maybe you
didn't want to interfere
with the application being
used at the time.
So by understanding that, hey,
I'm not on a great quality
network, I'm going to wait
until I see this number pop up,
then I'm going to
try and shoot it.
And you can also
use Job Scheduler
to help with some of that, too.
This is just kind of-- there's
a whole bunch of sessions
that Google has done
on Job Scheduler
that you might find really
nice and actually really want
to go Joanna's Doze
thing at some point,
but I know it's happening
at the same time.
Does that answer your
question a little bit?
All right.
Cool.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STACY DEVINO: So I've
found that WebP quality is
a little bit higher
than regular JPEG,
but I think it also
depends on what compressor
you use on your JPEG.
I'm not super great
at knowing everything.
So I'm a little bit of a pixel
fiend, so I'm definitely like,
we have to have
high-quality assets.
But at the same point in time,
you have to determine what is
worth the quality
and what isn't.
So maybe a square that's just a
background square-- maybe that
doesn't need to be a
high-quality square.
But maybe something
where it's a picture
of a product or a
picture of somebody,
that needs to be high quality.
So you need to
determine what that
needs to be based off of how
it's being contextually used.
And it's always different in
different organizations, too.
So retail, always make
the product look good.
Signage, look
pretty good, but it
doesn't have to look nearly
as good as the product does.
The product has to look like,
oh man, I want it so bad.
So there's just
different ways you have
to handle it based off of that.
Any other questions?
Yay!
All right.
What is the mantra?
Compress your images.
Everybody compress them.
So thank you so much for coming,
and I super appreciate it.
You can feel free to come up
and ask me anything else if you
wanted to privately.
[APPLAUSE]